Speaker 1: All right, let us waste no time
because we have such an agenda here at the
start of today's show. Updated numbers for
Democrats and Republicans in the House and
Senate in what now are midterm elections that
are just about six weeks away. Numbers continue
to improve for Democrats in both the House and
Senate, although Democrats are still not favored
to win in the House. Let's look at the numbers in
the FiveThirtyEight forecast for the Senate 2022.
It is now a 71% chance that Democrats will win and
only a 29% chance that Republicans will win. The
most likely outcomes are Democrats maintaining a
5050 majority because Kamala Harris would be the
tie breaking vote vote or Democrats having a 51
to 49 advantage. The way that these numbers have
changed over the last several months is directly
in the favor of Democrats. As you can see,
if you're looking at the screen, at the beginning
of June, Democrats had about a 40% chance of
holding the Senate. That has climbed steadily
to a new high of 71%. Now, things that happened,
29% of the sorry, things that are 29% likely to
happen. Happened 29 out of every 100 times. So
that doesn't mean that there is any guarantee
here. But right now, the most mathematically
likely scenario is Democrats holding the Senate
either 5050 or 51 to 49. Now, over in the House,
the numbers are not looking as good for Democrats,
but the numbers are closing in on basically a 2 to
1 likelihood of Republicans taking the House,
which is far worse for Republicans than it has
been at any previous point during this election
cycle. 28% chance for Democrats. And again,
if we look at how those numbers have shifted over
time, you will see that what was at one point
a 14% chance for Democrats, at one point a 12%
chance for Democrats has now surged all the way
up to a 28% chance. Again, the most likely outcome
is still that the Republicans will take control of
the House, but the likelihood of that has declined
steadily for a period of June, July, August,
three and a half months, three and a half months,
as we've said before, if at this same rate,
the numbers continue to improve for Democrats.
By Election Day, it would be close to 5050.
We don't know that that's going to happen,
but that's the way the numbers look today.
And the important thing is everyone must vote.
Do not concede any seat. Fight for everything.